we're continuing to monitor the funeral
procession of George Floyd in Houston
Texas as you can see his body now being
taken by a team of horses to his final
resting place
meanwhile in other big news even more
confusion about how the corona virus
spreads the World Health Organization is
doing a 180 after making this stunning
claim
yesterday about transmitting the virus
we have a number of reports from
countries who are doing very detailed
contact tracing they're following
asymptomatic cases they're following
contacts and they're not finding
secondary transmission on word is very
rare the w-h-o now forced to walk back
those comments this morning they're
saying now that as many as 41% of the
population could have the virus without
displaying any symptoms they can I got
to tell you this is like what am I to
think so
Dagan is it that they just don't know
that this is evolving that this is
science what do you what do you make of
this
I don't know one I don't speak or read
idiocy so this is why we're defunding
the World Health Organization this is
not the whu-oh has done this repeatedly
just in April the whu-oh said antibodies
had not been shown to provide any
immunity to the corona virus to Cove in
1912 hours later it had to reverse
itself and then this this is my favorite
gem from the whu-oh that helped unleash
this deadly virus on the US and the
world preliminary investigations
conducted by Chinese authorities have
found no clear evidence of
human-to-human transmission of the novel
coronavirus identified in Wuhan China
January 14th
a week later reversed course by the way
that's about the time my friend who
lives here in New York City contracted
it this organization is literally deadly
so Brian you know we're all humans we're
all worried about the virus this roads
trusting at least that's the way I'm
thinking what do you think
one I think so many things it's hard to
keep it clear between the mass issue
between it's not gonna spread
human-to-human between oh my goodness if
it gets on any countertop or chair don't
touch it or else you're gonna you're
gonna get the virus then all of a sudden
it's very rare to be able to pick up
this virus by a countertop or touching
anything really which one is it don't
wear a mask I wear a mask everywhere
we're not going to serve you
really okay now asymptomatic you really
can't get it from someone asymptomatic
hours later they walk it back with the
walk back makes no sense and this is it
I'm okay with doctors and scientists
being wrong I am NOT okay with
destroying people's livelihoods because
we're counting on them to be right and
we gave you 15 days you asked for 30
then 45 days we're in day 100 and a
restaurant can open in most kind of in
most states in this huge city called New
York City and Los Angeles you can't go
to a gym you can buy liquor but you
can't buy a postcard this is you can go
to the post office and go to a
supermarket but you can't buy cleats who
made up these rules we're gonna look
back and say how did the American people
become such sheep because they continued
to make us feel like idiots because we
listened to them and gave them credit
and I just think about all those small
businesses that are never coming back
that you pour yourself in for a hundred
hours a week to make a restaurant work
and then it's destroyed because some guy
in a with a stethoscope says you better
shut it down or everyone's gonna die and
it turns out it's just not the case well
I mean I can't I can't agree with that
because I think we've got a hundred you
know thousand people dead so something's
going on but but you know Jesse to me
doctor foul Chi in an interview that
aired today said this is not even over
this is he says we're just getting
through the beginning that there's more
to come again I am a little bit I hope
the audience has a clearer view than I
do but I trust voci but here he is
saying we're not even at the beginning
we're just at the beginning I should say
well maybe the audience usually has a
more clear now I'm not going to say it
one no I mean WTF wh Oh like they got it
wrong on China transmission
hydroxychloroquine the anybody's pretty
much everything but the left wants to
fund the w-h-o and they want to defund
the police you see how who works and if
you think about it the wh o has probably
been more deadly in 2020 then the police
of the United States so go figure
I think what we need to do because this
is such a political organization we need
to make a new international Health
Organization and appoint dr. Siegal to
be the president of it that's when we
can get through the woods and then Brian
can buy again is that right from dr.
Siegel I mean I when I looked at the
numbers before the show it said that it
since the start of June they've actually
been a increase in the rates of
infection in 14 states and Puerto Rico
as I was saying earlier a hundred and
nine thousand people have died 1.9
million reported cases of people
contracting the virus so if that's the
case and we have these conflicting
indicators from the scientists where are
you what are you thinking I feel like
there has just been an absolute collapse
of the ability for our major
institutions especially in public health
to communicate clearly to the public I
feel that if they don't know the answers
to some things that that would be more
understandable than having all of these
flip flops it's like John Kerry in the
2004 election I can't keep my head
straight on my mom went to the grocery
store for the first time in four months
today and because she finally had the
confidence and Colorado is opening she's
able to be able to go they have to do a
better job because Americans will not
stand for this again
Dana thank you